um first lady melania trump did not take
president trump's hand while walking
down the steps from air force long along
with their son barron
so there's trouble in paradise now
they're saying that the trumps don't get
along
it's like they never got along like what
do you think we all know she doesn't
want to be there
i know yeah i feel like melanie trump
yeah she will take his head i love it
watch what
it is yeah get it off yeah yeah yeah
get off me don't touch me old man
because
i mean he can't he can't look good naked
it's gross
it's got to be tough for her because
she's still a piece yeah i mean
he he is that thing it's funny it's
funny that i mean she just doesn't give
a [ __ ] i mean do you understand
how [ __ ] frustrating it's got to be
to be the both of them she doesn't want
to be there
and then he tries to hold her hand and
she makes him look stupid in public it's
just like
it's a horrible situation that they both
but they i do you think as soon as he's
done being the president they're going
to get divorced
or you think they just don't know i
think they just have an arrangement
where like she bangs out some dude
and like he's just the president she
just disappears they got that son
and the son apparently is a young andrew
schultz
i mean look at the kid here he comes he
looks like andrew
because andrew schultz is a tall drink
of water he's a skinny kid
and that kind of could be there he is
yeah
young andrew schultz yeah there is i
mean but this he's the youngest one
right this kid
yeah yeah he's the he's the only one for
these from these two
i mean look at how tall that kid is he's
a tall [ __ ] glass of water good kid
and you know he looks like a good kid
this kid yeah he looks like a good kid
isn't he isn't trump like six four or
what is he yeah trump's a big kid
so that kid is like six seven yeah he's
a big [ __ ] kid
i mean he's probably not his son she
probably banged out you know i mean
slovenia they're tall kids in slovenia
yeah who's this [ __ ] eastern hemi
guys because i mean that i mean baron
trump could play
could maybe play center one day for st
joe's basketball no
it's what it is yeah cause division
three [ __ ] signups really hope you
enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode so
go make sure you rate review us
subscribe
uh turn on your notifications get jiggy
with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]